ellos con mi hermana tanda
a 7,60 lines estatua kilo
musical
[Música]
qué tal oyentes y ciber seguidores de
radio canadá internacional bienvenidos a
su programa canadá en las américas café
el castor cibernético también lo
conocemos así los saluda paloma martínez
desde los estudios de radio canadá
internacional aquí en montreal damos la
bienvenida a toda la gente que nos está
viendo por medios sociales por facebook
live youtube youtube live en nuestro
sitio
con las dos gracias por acompañarnos
aquí en el programa estaremos hablando
hoy de juventud y de política mezcladas
rupa rupa y aquí en el estudio
leonardo gimeno qué tal leo algunos
vídeos luis laborda que tal muy buenos
días muy buenas tardes muy buenas noches
y tenemos una invitada especial que les
presentamos en un momentito
como cada semana esta semana les
hablaremos de entrevistas reportajes
artículos que marcaron la actualidad
canadiense y latinoamericana y también
leeremos algunos de sus mensajes todos
los que nos llegan nunca damos abasto a
nunca leemos todos los que no llegan
porque nos llegan muchos y de hecho
también estaremos viendo lo que la gente
nos comenta durante el programa en
facebook live así que no sean tímido el
problema siempre el mismo el tiempo no
hablamos demasiado hablamos de verdad
entonces no nos queda tiempo para hablar
más además lo que es cierto es que
cuando hablamos demasiado nos damos
cuenta que la gente si nos sigue y
fuimos nominados leonardo tenemos que
hablar de este señor otra vez no
nominados como lo hablaba hace un ratito
sobre la denominación no como en los
nominados estar listo para salir sino
nominados en los latin awards canadá
2018 fuimos nominados en 2017 y
sorpresivamente ganamos
sorpresivamente porque en realidad bueno
no sabíamos porque aparte es una es una
una cosa bastante interesante porque la
iluminación uno se puede postular y
dentro del consejo que eligen las
denominaciones lo ponen a uno o no en la
categoría y nosotros no lo sabíamos
porque no teníamos una idea así que
fuimos a alguien que nos sigue nos
presentó la candidatura fue aceptada y
fuimos los ganadores en esa categoría en
el 2017 fue el mejor programa web por
canal de las américas café el castor
mensajero
web así que pero no por la página de
internet
así que tenemos muchísima información
que tenemos bueno un trabajo constante
con tres periodistas durante los cinco
días hábiles de la semana preparamos
contenidos para el fin de semana y tal o
sea es muy completa pero nuevamente
hemos sido nominados para el premio al
mejor programa web así que bueno vamos a
mostrar un poquito y yo quiero comentar
que también es sorpresivo porque la
verdad que los candidatos los otros
nominados también tenían mucho valor de
periodístico en los programas son muy
interesantes entonces claro sorpresivos
y contentos del año pasado y esperemos
que este año la gente vote por nosotros
uno ninguno había había candidatos había
nominados muy integran competencia pero
casta la verdad
al presidente y al creador de este de
este concurso digamos que llama a nivel
cruz y el año pasado una cosa muy
interesante porque estuvo la que hoy es
la
alcaldesa de montreal se presentó
participando y habló dos o tres palabras
en español y dijo no espero que el voto
latino de ganar y ganó así que yo le
pregunté si había otras sorpresas como
otro para alguna otra persona de
política que fuera a presentarse este
año para que estuvieran asistirá en la
gala para ver si va a ganar o no en las
próximas elecciones me dijo bueno un
montón de gente que va a participar pero
no desde ese punto de vista que habían
sido muy afortunados el año pasado en
tener la presencia de la alcaldesa
alcaldesa de montreal que en realidad en
aquel momento
eso es quien ayudó a quien no sé si
estás a nosotros es a nosotros nosotros
llegó que la comunidad latinoamericana
de montreal es muy importante muy activa
muy movilizada entonces yo no digo que
hayan sido ellos pero es alcaldesa
gracias yo creo y esta exposición
personal yo creo que ella es alcaldesa
porque él
anterior alcalde le hizo un gran favor
haciendo un montón de locuras bueno
también es alcaldesa porque es joven
porque es mujer y porque monta le estaba
listo también creo para eso sino para la
juventud
nos va bien vamos entonces a hablar
justamente de política y de juventud
[Música]
ah
no no no no
[Música]
como
no
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cada elección me parece que las
autoridades electorales los repiten lo
dicen lo repiten los jóvenes no están
implicados en política a los jóvenes no
les interesan ni ser candidatos ni
participar como electores no se implican
suficiente el poder que tendrían los
jóvenes de cambiar las cosas a través de
su voto a través de sus candidaturas
podría ser enorme pero siempre nos dicen
que no se implican suficientes la horita
se vivió cuando las manifestaciones de
los estudiantes la cambia es necesario
en 2012 fue eso fue extraordinario pero
igualmente después de eso tampoco se
reconoce una participación juvenil o
ciudadana en políticas de hecho muchos
muchos jóvenes creen que no es a través
de la política política que los cambios
van a llegar en las sociedades pero hoy
les presentamos aquí en el estudio a una
excepción que confirma la regla
alejandra saga méndez bienvenida a
canadá en las américas café cómo le va
muchas gracias por la invitación muy
bien usted es candidata por el partido
que becks sólida en las inscripción
burguesa sube de montreal enlace
provinciales de que ve que tendrán lugar
en octubre próximo
alejandra ustedes ustedes candidata de
esta circunscripción que representa una
de las más pobres del canadá como se
explica esta realidad de montreal norte
en particular que es el nombre que le
damos más conocido a esta misma
circunscripción electoral exacto el
mismo los electores de montreal norte
cuando les digo que que la que esta
circunscripción se llama bocazas sobre
no sé si no se reconoce y encima de
marjal no es un lugar muy particular
aquí en quebec porque no solamente es un
lugar con una gran alta tasa de pobreza
y desempleo pero también es un barrio en
que mucha población inmigrante yo crecí
en montreal norte mantra el norte es
como me dio mi barrio de acogida es ahí
donde aprendí lo que es el quebec ahí
aprendí el francés y como explicamos
esta desigualdad social bueno no hay que
mentirnos en los últimos años ha habido
muchas políticas públicas
en lugar de sostener y dar un apoyo a
las comunidades inmigrantes las
comunidades pobres han cortado los
recursos en educación en salud y en
servicios sociales y lo que hemos visto
es que entre el 2006 y el 2011 este
abismo que que se está creando entre
montreal norte y resto de quebec ha
aumentado ahí hay un abismo de 15 mil
dólares que falta anual manualmente
en fort familia en los ingresos de las
familias es enorme mismo 42 por ciento
de los trabajadores en su ingreso
personal
ganan menos de 20 mil dólares al año eso
es lo que llamamos estar en una
situación de progreso y en canadá es ese
es el límite la pobreza el 20 mil
dólares anual entonces es un lugar con
muchos desafíos y creo que son esos
desafíos que a mí me me motivan hacer
política justamente la idea de preguntar
qué es lo que usted propondría como
candidata viendo el panorama que
montreal norte tiene en este momento qué
es lo que usted propone qué es lo que su
partido
para lugares como esa región de montera
porque no es el único lugar en donde
nombres en la región de monte
en quebec en general general que es lo
que propone este exactamente las
propuestas de quebec solidaire están muy
con seis se encuentran raíz en esos
problemas sociales en una de las de las
luchas más grandes que he llevado como
en el partido y ahora como ha sido
aceptado en la provincia de ontario y la
necesidad s surge porque nos damos
cuenta que cuando uno gana 12 dólares
ahora no vive sobrevive sitges y nos
está pidiendo un sueldo mínimo de 30
horas equiparar y que uno pueda tener
los oficiales exactos lo suficiente y lo
mínimo estamos hablando de lo mínimo y
ahora en el 2018 para que una familia
pueda mantenerse a otra cosa que yo veo
en este barrio es que hay muchas
familias monoparentales con solamente
que existe madres solteras y una madre
soltera gana 12 dólares la hora y tiene
dos hijos
es imposible estamos con d
a gente a la pobreza entonces yo he
trabajado mucho con asociaciones de
trabajadores sobre todo inmigrantes
trabajadores que no están sindicalizados
para lograr esta alza de 15 horas la
hora somos el único partido que hemos
llevado esta proposición hasta la
asamblea nacional el año pasado con un
proyecto de ley para reformar la forma
que votamos el salario mínimo no hemos
tenido respuesta pero seguimos en la
lucha ahora lo que hay que mencionar es
que 15 dólares la hora para la gente que
nos está escuchando en américa latina le
puede parecer una fortuna porque en
ningún país de américa latina ninguna
pero bueno algunos trabajadores sí pero
no son digamos la mayoría de los
trabajadores pueden imaginarse una vida
en la que sean pagados 15 dólares la
hora pero en canadá con los precios de
la comida con los precios de las de las
residencias con los precios en general
de transporte pública dinero porción es
proporcional entonces es un es un
salario que además ha sido reconocido en
otras provincias con un particularmente
en ontario como lo mínimo para vivir
bien y no caer en la pobreza como el
tema del piso de los 20 mil dólares de
los que ella hablaba hace unos instantes
y cuando uno dice veinte mil
en algunos países eso puede sonar a
mucho dinero pero tomando en cuenta la
ley de económica de canadá y de quebec
20 mil dólares no es prácticamente nada
alguien que gana 20 incluso 25 mil
dólares que no sé si no es es el piso
salarial es 22 mil dólares para la
pobreza bueno muchos pobres si ganan
menos de 22 mil dólares un salario que
en otras latitudes sería bueno aquí es
apenas la base o el básico mejor dicho
que no alcanza ni siquiera cubrir gastos
que pueden ser por ejemplo gastos
particulares especiales de salud de
medicinas y hablando de salud es una
otra la segunda propuesta en la cual
estamos trabajando es el seguro dental
el seguro dental porque es una necesidad
hay que entender que en quebec el seguro
dental es privado bueno si quiere ir al
al dentista tienen que tener un seguro
privado y lo que vemos es que yo veo
familias sobre todo latinoamericanas que
me dicen que le sale más barato por
tomarse un avión ir a su país de origen
a curarse su dentadura en vez de
ofrecernos aquí un seguro público y esa
es la segunda propuesta
que demos que es una necesidad no es un
lujo curarse una caries y lo que estamos
viendo es que la repartición la riqueza
pasa ahí pasa dándonos según un seguro
de salud que cubre ampliamente todas
nuestras necesidades ofrecer a los niños
hasta los 18 años un seguro gratis de
prevención y de curación y a las
personas adultas cubrir entre 60 y 80%
cuando se habló de los costos de la
salud dental en américa del norte en
general por supuesto en eeuu son mucho
más altos que aquí más aquí también son
'la son muy altos los profesionales de
la salud los odontólogos y todos los
profesionales ligados en la salud dental
dicen que los costos para ellos también
son altísimos entonces es realista
plantear una cobertura generalizada como
la que vos propones tomando en cuenta
que esos costos dentarios la actividad
dental aquí en américa del norte son
muchos más elevados que en otra parte
estamos en condiciones de cubrir sus
costos
estos números creemos que sí porque
hemos empezado a tener reuniones con
todas las asociaciones de higienistas
las persona
que se encargan de hacer una prevención
y una de las cosas que vemos es que los
costos son muy altos para los
odontólogos y los dentistas porque ellos
absolutamente un higienista tiene que
trabajar con un dentista al mismo tiempo
una de las cosas que proponemos es dar a
los técnicos en higiene dental una
autonomía como las enfermeras para que
puedan hacer más trabajo preventivo
conocemos más trabajo preventivo no
llegamos a una a un problema más grande
que sea una infección bucal del otro
lado eso baja los costos y del otro lado
el segundo presunto defecto que tiene es
que podemos regular una tarifa para todo
el mundo igual porque si no se cree una
competencia entre los dentistas entre
ellos hubo hablé ser como un noble ser
extra para esta cosa de baja base y el
tercer efecto es que aumenta la demanda
ahora hay mucha gente que no va al
dentista porque no tiene dinero ni
cobertura éxito ni cobertura no tiene
recursos para pagarlo entonces no
podemos el dentista no recibe esos
beneficios hay una persona sobre cuatro
en quebec sea 25 por ciento que no pone
en pie
en una dentista al año estos 25 de
nuestro problema yo conozco un caso hace
muchos años atrás cuando todavía ha
llegado que estuve en el bienestar
social y había una persona que estaba en
estado social y se había quedado más del
tiempo que le correspondía porque a
partir de los creo que eran dos años o
tres años de estar bajo el sistema de de
civilidad social uno recibir atención
bucal y él tenía que arreglarse los
dientes y tenía la posibilidad sería
trabajar y no quería hacerlo porque en
él la posibilidad trabajar de laboral ya
no le brindaba seguro entonces ni
siquiera trabajando a tiempo completo
con un buen sueldo podía pagarse el
arreglo de su boca entonces espero para
poder hacerse tratar el tratamiento
grande digamos lo hizo bajo el bienestar
social aprovechándose del sistema para
poder salida es un incentivo que
queremos lo que queremos es que la gente
trabaje en las buenas condiciones de
trabajo porque es la única forma que
bueno cómo funciona el sistema aquí es
que cuando otros trabajamos
nuestros impuestos y esos impuestos
tiene que ser redistribuidos en servicio
de contribuir a la sociedad trabajando
pero eso quiere decir que la sociedad
también por supuesto y lo que es tan una
mentalidad un poco peleada con
idiosincrasia en américa del norte
diciendo bueno claro pero eso es los
valores y es parte de la visión política
y social que defendemos si solamente
quería aclarar por un paloma un segundo
solamente es cuando hablamos del
problema de acceso a la salud dental no
estamos hablando de pobres solamente
mucha gente mayor conozco gente queremos
el agua porque voy a las todas las
puertas y gente que tiene un salario un
buen salario pero me dice pagó tres mil
dólares la semana a la segunda pasada
para de tres mil dólares porque me
faltaba falta un diente es actualmente
ahora una cosa que es criticada con su
partido particularmente recibe críticas
con frecuencia por ser considerado como
un partido idealista un partido de
soñadores ayer particularmente lo
criticaron por haber propuesto un
ambicioso y bastante caro proyecto de un
sistema de transporte
público para toda la región
metropolitana de montreal que le
responden ustedes a la gente que le
responde usted particularmente alejandra
a la gente que le dice no es posible
imaginarse ese tipo de proyectos que son
tan caros para la sociedad son demasiado
grandes demasiado caros y son idealistas
que les responde usted primero que para
hacer política hay que tener ambición y
estamos en una sociedad que
lamentablemente está frente a un muro y
que nuestras generaciones que vienen van
a pagar un precio muy alto por los
cambios con los cambios climáticos y con
los problemas ambientales pues tener una
ambición ambiental de decir tenemos que
darnos un sistema de transporte público
apto al siglo 21 para nosotros no ser
realistas es ser responsables porque si
nos comparamos a otras metrópolis en
europa estamos a años luz de de dar un
servicio el ejemplo
lo conozco en contra del norte no
tenemos un metro tenemos que tomar un
autobús de 30 a 40 minutos para llegar
y de ahí otros 30 minutos más para ir al
centro esas dos horas diarias en la vida
de un trabajador que pasan en un tren el
tráfico en un transporte que no es
eficiente esos manuales va bien dos
horas porque a veces es más lado es como
una hora y media una hora y no debería
correr a regreso y si a veces cuando la
casa se está cayendo porque nuestro
planeta se está cayendo tenemos que
invertir y en un momento dado invertir
ahora más va a ser que los costos al
arroz tiempo van a ser menos si yo tengo
el caso yo viaje
tres meses de estudios en madrid en el
año 1997 no sé si ustedes 97 fui a hacer
un curso en madrid y me traje de
recuerdo el plan del metro de madrid que
en ese momento tenía 10 líneas un amigo
mío volvió de madrid hace 6 meses me
mostró el plan de metro y tienen 8
líneas más tienen 18 líneas ahora y
pasaron 20 años desde el año 67 hasta
hoy cuántas líneas más de metro ahí en
montreal 0 creo que ha habido cuatro
nuevas en la zona del norte de
exactamente y bueno yo también tuve la
oportunidad de ser en berlín el año
pasado y me quedé sorprendida a qué
punto dan una oportunidad de transporte
colectivo transporte activo o un
transporte individual y eso es lo que
nosotros proponemos dar una opción y si
nos va a costar dinero y si cuando uno
llega y dice oh a mí ya realidad va a
cambiar tanto nos da miedo entonces en
ese momento nos acusan de tiene muchos
mucha ambición
en miedo de que el estado de quebec se
endeude y no quiere que las no quieren
que el estado esté entregado por
proyectos ambiciosos que cuestan en el
en el caso del proyecto del sistema de
transporte público para montreal es 25
mil millones de dólares que costaría si
es mucho dinero es mucho dinero no le
puedo decir lo contrario y lo que si no
regresa un poco en los años 60 cuando
hablamos de hydro québec o cuando
hablamos del metro de montreal las
críticas eran las mismas y 50 años
después que vemos vemos los resultados
de tener un transporte público porque
montreal y ha sido muy envidiado en los
años 70 por su transporte público en
norteamérica pero lamentablemente no
llegó a una evolución y por tener por
ejemplo en el caso hydro québec una
compañía estatal que ofrecen la
electricidad así que yo creo que debemos
lanzarnos en esta aventura y además hay
que decirlo quienes critican esta
propuesta de inversión en el caso de tu
partido pero hablo en general no lo
estoy haciendo con acciones reguladas
mucho menos no lo además lo que nos
toman en cuenta es cuáles son los costos
los que demanda las demoras que un
habitante de esta ciudad debe vivir
todos los días cuando se sube a un
autobús que tarda 40 minutos en hacer un
trayecto que debería demorarse 10
minutos cuando el metro todos los días
presenta problemas de funcionamiento
cuando subirse a un auto para cruzar uno
de los puentes que une montreal con la
ribera norte de la ribera solo implica
estar 50 minutos parados sin avanzar
gastando combustible malgastando se
adelantaron a exactamente entonces esa
gente no toma en cuenta que eso también
es un gasto y no solamente es un gasto
sino que es un gasto que no suma
absolutamente nada cuando se habla de
propuestas de inversión en
infraestructura quienes critican no
toman en cuenta que esta ciudad y esta
sociedad hace décadas décadas abandonó
la noción de progreso material ya que en
lo que se refiere a inversión en
infraestructura y no hay ciudad que
pueda existir ni mantener su salud si no
invierte en infraestructura louis
presidentes
el miércoles pasado lamentablemente un
accidente de la isla un accidente
cancelaron seis viajes de del tren que
va a ser nuestra en la que es digamos
fundan el corazón del transporte es el
oeste la isla y yo tuve que viajar dos
horas para llegar también a buscar mira
que las opciones nos sobra porque nos
sobran exactamente y sobre todo que las
periferias no están conectadas tenemos
que pasar por un centro persuadir a la
de al lado que normalmente en 20 minutos
esos 22 horas deberían tomar 20 minutos
y bueno podemos creo que muchas personas
tienen esta necesidad nosotros lo único
que estamos sin desarticular articular
la perdón cuando un proyecto
infraestructura y que no lo hemos sacado
en nuestra cabeza hemos ido a ver toda
la sociedad de transporte que reciben
desde décadas demandas proyectos
y lo que queremos es poner todos juntos
y ver cuál
la solución y que le podemos proponer a
toda la gente de montreal ahora usted no
es la única joven en la en la región en
esa circunscripción hay otra candidata a
julie y necesita seguir perdón de la
coalición a venir que ve que quesería a
la coalición por el futuro de quebec y
vamos a estar conversando con ella la
próxima semana para ver qué piensa de
estas mismas realidades de las que usted
está hablando en esa región
particularmente pero que tocan a toda la
región de montreal ahora sí entonces
estamos comprobando con usted y con
julie que la juventud se está implicando
particularmente en esas regiones de
montalt ellas de origen haitiano también
entonces representa bien digamos la zona
porque justamente hay muchos
latinoamericanos hay muchos haitianos en
esa en esa circunscripción de montreal
norte y entonces la juventud está
implicada por lo menos de allí usted
recuerda a nuestros oyentes es candidata
por el partido que becks sólida en la
circunscripción burguesa sube de
montreal
alejandra zaga méndez también es
estudiante de doctorado en desarrollo
sostenible licenciada en ciencias
agrícolas
por la universidad mcgill de montreal y
maestro en ciencias de los recursos
naturales en gestión de recursos en
gestión de recursos naturales
alejandra saga méndez mes muchas gracias
y decir merci muchas gracias por venir a
nuestros estudios muchas gracias por el
tiempo y la interés que tienen en mi
candidatura hasta una próxima vez en
muchísimas gracias hola soy daniel años
garcía pianista colombiano que vive en
montreal trabajo con los ensambles la
machine y el asamblea lo oyen y los
invito a vivir canadá en las américas
café de radio canadá internacional en la
web
así fue sin musiquita pero como están
tenemos temas esta semana que estuvimos
tratando varios temas interesantes
siempre trabajamos duro y presentamos
cosas interesantes aquí en nuestro
programa pero antes de pasar a los temas
serios y fuertes quería hablar de uno
que es menos serio porque pero que está
bueno menos serio entre comillas porque
si nos vamos hacia el fondo al fondo
también es serio es de los o en ottawa
vieron
los fanáticos de los osos aquí es luz
aquí hay un tema ligado los osos
lo voy a reemplazar esta semana porque
en el monte en ottawa que es la capital
de canadá en el mero centro de la ciudad
a las 3 de la mañana del jueves o sea de
ayer las autoridades de emergencia de
urgencia recibieron una llamada que
había un oso cerca del mercado byward
que es el mercado que está ahí en el
mero mero centro en un minuto y medio
del parlamento canadiense alguien había
visto un oso un osito negro osito tan
gran bueno yo sí lo veo cerca tal vez no
parece no tan chico pero igual no parece
tan grande y lo encontraron ahí hay un
vídeo tenemos un vídeo vemos el vídeo
sobre si del osito de agua no parece muy
violento te diría no sabes que yo creo
que se asustó
no era un grizzly porque los grizzlies
son se asustan tal vez alejandra que
está todavía aquí en el estudio nos
puede decir que eso es un oso negro
canadiense es una zona agro canadiense
platters y yo creo que tenía hambre a
los animales acerca de si tienen hambre
pero a mí lo que me preocupa es decir
monte de ottawa tampoco está tan así tan
cerca de zonas boscosas no de hecho
activa decir cuándo cuando yo me enteré
de la noticia pensé que había sido en
gatineau que está enfrente ottawa que
ahí sí porque hay un parque enorme que
es el parque de aquino que está de
espaldas a la ciudad o la ciudad está de
espaldas del parque en todo caso y yo
conozco gente que vive no muy lejos del
centro de gatineau y que sin más una vez
se ha encontrado con pequeños osos que
andan dando vueltas por ir buscando
alimento porque se salen del parque para
buscar alimento el tema se como gracias
ahora a nadar será muy efectivo nada
cuenta que todos los automóviles sacarán
bueno
y entonces andaba de compras disfrazado
para una fiesta de disfraces
todo eso duró el día entero porque desde
la mañana las 3 de la mañana quien habló
fueron a verlo encontraron lo siguieron
lo estuvieron siguiendo siguiendo
siguiendo siguiendo cerraron el centro
de ottawa está completamente cerrado
porque es la capital del país y tuvieron
que ser a todo el centro yo ya he visto
en lugares más alejados desde la costa
oeste canadiense hay un formulario del
correo de canadá que dice vinimos a
verlo no podemos entrar porque había un
oso en su barrio
pero entonces o sea no es raro cuando
las poblaciones tan cerca de lugares
donde hay osos pero es un poco tampoco
les han alejado por las dudas por si los
osos se están acercando cada vez más
recordemos dentro del tono jocoso de la
nota que
uno de los consejos habituales que se
dan a los encuentros con osos en todo
canadá son más que frecuentes es no
correr y si se encuentran con un oso hay
dos cosas básicas que no hay que hacer
no hay que darle la espalda hay que
enfrentarlo hay que mirarlo todo el
tiempo y no hay que correr porque porque
puede ser que se trate de un oso
simpático que nuevo este y saca a jugar
y crea que estamos jugando contra él
entonces se nos venga encima tiene
garras y corre más rápida de masada
corre más rápido y cuando intentan
precisamente entre en contacto físico
con uno lo que hacen es voluntaria
comunitariamente desplegar las garras
que tienen que son bastante grandes
bastante grandes y arañas o menor más
puede cortar por la mitad entonces si se
ayuda de cuidar bueno yo ya tuve una
experiencia de oso y como a uno a mí me
dieron un abrazo de 8 alguna vez no yo
como unos 25 metros vi dos ositos y yo
hice exactamente lo contrario lo que
acaba de sugerir me dio miedo y corrí
correcto y en el bottino que siguieron
no no me siguieron
me podrían haber seguido que no me
vieron yo los vi
y felizmente la mamá tampoco mi vida no
esos son consejos que se dan muy
frecuentemente en la costa oeste donde
los encuentros con los nuestros son muy
muy muy frecuentes es no dar la espalda
y no correr exactamente
bueno pues al final del día les cuento
lo otro le pusieron un sedante lo
bajaron del árbol porque subió a 8
metros él estaba editó el día y pasó el
tiempo 8 a 8 metros de altura a nadie se
le acercaba después finalmente le
lanzaron un dardo con un poco de sedante
y lo calmaron y ya se durmió y lo
bajaron medio adormilado lógico no lo
llevaron de nuevo a la zona de datos de
la que vienen esos osos bueno es el tema
chistoso del día ahora los temas que
ustedes estuvieron tratando esta semana
león el tema cría saluda a la gente pero
se fue la gente que nos está saludando
en este caso no pablo gómez trabajo
viendo juego de javier gonzález nunca
dice hola
johnny will y navarros saludos desde
perú y en especial a paloma que se le
vuelve a escuchar después de mucho
tiempo siguen adelante con las buenas
ondas pablo dice apoyo a la emoción luis
presidente y ministro seguro
[Risas]
y bueno leo entonces tu reportaje si
esta semana estuviese uno de tus
reportajes que presentaste esta semana
fue lo del algoritmo de inteligencia
artificial que podría determinar si
tenemos o no un empleo que estamos
buscando
no es el que determina el empleo sino
que este algoritmo trabaja en realidad
depende de una empresa amor contra ghana
trabaja a favor en contra dependiendo de
lo que la empresa pida o sea yo soy una
empresa con muchísimo volumen de trabajo
y de puestos que mueven no porque por
ejemplo en las cuestiones tecnológicas
los trabajos se mueven mucho los puestos
son mucho la gente cambia de trabajo
rápidamente pues necesito cinco personas
y terminó haciendo entrevista por sorteo
se postulan 100 sorteo cinco de esos
cinco lejos mejor eso es lo que pasaba o
podría suceder o pasa aún en algunas
empresas en este caso en la empresa que
presenta este algoritmo lo que hace el
algoritmo es agarra a todas las personas
que se postulan firma un vídeo y con la
inteligencia artificial hace un análisis
de todos los datos el vídeo los
movimientos de los ojos los movimientos
la persona frente a cámara
sumado a el currículum y los aspectos
particulares y entonces hace como una
preselección de los candidatos que la
empresa esté dispuesto a inferir bien de
los criterios de la retención de los
criterios la empresa entonces la empresa
viene agarra esos cinco que ya fueron
preseleccionados y hace las entrevistas
y elige el mejor postulante lo que pasa
es que la historia de esto es
interesante porque nace desde la
cuestión del prejuicio
no nace porque esta gente dijo bueno hay
mucha gente y no todos llegan no no no
una de las personas que lanza el
proyecto el dueño de uno de los dueños
de la empresa de los fundadores de esta
empresa pasó dos años buscando trabajo y
no consigue trabajo como se llamaba ahí
tengo el nombre para saber a deformar el
nombre no es un nombre digamos muy aquí
está ese es el muchacho le voy a mostrar
giants ansari giant ansari mandaba un
currículum con su nombre y no lo digamos
no pasaba no llegaba nunca la entrevista
en el cabro entre entrevistas y alguien
le dijo a él leí un artículo que dice
que a veces los nombres son tomados y no
es un nombre muy común no retienen la
candidatura porque no te pones john
smith ansari pero jon y es efectivamente
eso fue lo que hizo a las cuatro semanas
los llamaron tuvo dos entrevistas con su
trabajo entonces él mismo se dijo que
ese tipo de digamos de preselección está
en viciada y que hay gente que quizás no
lo hace con ánimo
pero se hace danza y hay estudios que
dicen que pasa está bien entonces para
evitar eso él propone este algoritmo que
toma a todas las personas hombres
mujeres no también cuenta y no cuenta
los nombres toma en cuenta lo que dice
el cb y después
y lo que se ve en
en la entrevista pero no se le nota ni
color de piel ni como viene vestido sino
los movimientos en las facciones la
disposición frente a la cámara y eso es
lo que hace una preselección mucho más
equitativa digamos pues interesante a
porque es verdad que mucha gente hemos
visto algunos estudios que hablan de esa
cuestión del nombre y la selección más
bien
el conseguir o no un trabajo en función
del nombre que uno tiene si me puedo
permitir creo que es muy interesante
porque evita todo este tipo acá le dice
en discriminación del primer encuentro
cuando cuando leen el cb pero es
lamentable que lleguemos a eso
exactamente es decir ya mí me gustaba
más la teoría de que como hay muchos
postulantes entonces la inteligencia
artificial hacia una preselección para
evitar que esa gente espere me gustaba
más ese punto claro pero cuando uno ve
por qué lo por que empieza la historia
que la norma sería que nos llamemos como
nos llamemos nos tienen que ver nuestra
cualificación y nuestra calidad es
social
podría ser la norma que a mí me parecía
eso por lo menos cuando yo sé que cuando
me enseñaron a hacer el cdl con el
currículum en argentina por ejemplo uno
pone edad sexo y situación social si es
casado o no si tiene hijos porque todo
el no aquí no no pones ni tus citas
punto situación marital ni sitios ruegos
conyugal ni si tienes hijos ni si tu
edad claro pero el hombre pesa ese es el
tema o sea nosotros se ha logrado que
todos esos datos salgan del papel para
evitar ese tipo de cuestiones y las
cuestiones pasan igualmente por nuestros
nombres vamos a tener tengo que cortar
es muy interesante el tema pero tenemos
que ir a otra cosa que es igual de
interesante tiempo luz pero el tiempo
nos estoy s nos está yendo como agua
entre las manos como dice pablo pablo
dice como los menos de dos cierto a
louis tú hablas de arquitectura
arquitectura orgánica sustentable
ecológica y hablaste con un experto de
sus temas
ching que viene desde méxico exactamente
vino aquí a dar una conferencia y a
inaugurar una exposición que se está
llevando a cabo en este momento hablamos
del arquitecto javier senosiáin
tiene una vasta trayectoria buscando
nuevas digamos nuevos horizontes para la
arquitectura y está inmerso actualmente
en un trabajo que tiene que ver algo con
lo que hablábamos con alejandra hace
unos instantes del desarrollo que van
siguiendo las ciudades él propone una
vuelta a las raíces es decir desandar de
alguna manera el proceso de desarrollo
que han seguido las ciudades desde la
revolución industrial sobre todo desde
antes pero desde la reducción del cal
sobre todo ni dejar de crear estas
aglomeraciones de cemento y de iu de
gente que no se encuentran muy a gusto
el uno con el otro y propone
precisamente esto volver a la ecología
volver a lo que es sustentable y volver
a lo que es orgánico y las imágenes son
hablan de por sí mismas de lo que él
propone a exactamente es me es muy
interesante él propone muchísimas cosas
pero para hacerla corta porque no
acabamos de decir no tenemos mucho
tiempo proponen la creación de lo que él
denomina ecobarrios estos ecos barrios
son casas que están semienterradas
rodeadas de espacios verdes
un grupo de estas casas constituyen el
ecobarrio un grupo de 6 ecobarrios
constituyen una ecociudad y un grupo de
6 ecociudades constituyen una mega eco
ciudad en ese contexto se encuentran los
barrios rodeados de espacios verdes con
los centros comerciales en el medio de
las casas así no hay tanto desplazan y
no hay desplazamientos no hay
necesidades de trazar grandes recorridos
y se eliminan la necesidad de utilizar
sobre todo el auto que es uno de los más
importantes contaminantes en la
actualidad y se utilizaría el transporte
público colectivo eléctrico para unir
los las mega o mejor dicho las
ecociudades es decir para moverse dentro
de la mega ecociudad es una propuesta
interesante como él decía difícil de
llevar a cabo hay muchas mentalidades
que hay que cambiar pero y lo dijo
alejandra hay cosas que ya están
cambiando nos guste o no nos guste
una de esas cosas es el nivel de
contaminación que nos rodea la escasez
de recursos que es cada vez más
angustiante y la propuesta que puede
sonar descabellada en este momento no lo
va a ser dentro de muy poco tiempo
cuando ya no tengamos estrés y espacio
para jugar para seguir jugando para mí
me encantó que la casa de don vito me
parece muy orgánica
y son muchísimos los arquitectos que
inicien desde hace tiempo de esto de
estar a uno le pasa yo vengo de la
ribera sur todos los días aquí a
trabajar cruzando un puente que debería
cruzar en el caso 5 o 10 minutos y venir
de la ribera sur para aquí me demanda
una obra de vida ajena por venir si no
me encanta en las complicaciones de
verdad si una hora de viaje el gasto de
combustible y emocional lo hemos hablado
entre nosotros fuera del micrófono y
hemos dejado de venir en auto porque es
además una locura conseguir estacionar
en asia entonces bueno hay que cambiar
y yo contrario les presentó esta semana
una entrevista con una artista pero no
hablamos de arte con ella resulta que un
café en toronto utilizó la imagen de
pablo escobar para promover su café y
claro que esto creó una gran
controversia porque hacían bromas con
respecto al hecho y más abajito lo vemos
en el reportaje en el artículo porque
dice pablo escobar es cobo porque él
argel el bar de perdón se llamaba café
coffee bar dice vendiendo el estimulante
la exportación número uno de colombia el
estimulante y entre paréntesis café
entonces es muchos latinoamericanos ni
siquiera fueron colombianos al principio
se ofendieron mucho porque dijeron
porque una persona porque estas personas
de este café que no conocen la historia
y las consecuencias del narcotráfico en
colombia y de la guerra que esto creo
pueden darse el lujo de utilizar la
imagen de este personaje sin
consultarnos sin tener esa sensibilidad
con respecto a la realidad de los
colombianos en colombia y por la cual
muchos han tenido que salir de colombia
que viven ahora aquí en canadá y no me
recordó a conversando con paola gómez
que es la artista que estuvo siguiendo
esto y que se quejó a la compañía y que
finalmente recibió un mensaje en el que
eligieron lo vamos a quitar para no
ofenderlos pero no para en cierto no
solo vamos a quitar para quitarnos de
problemas porque nosotros creemos en la
libertad de expresión y no queremos
ofender a nadie pero no porque hayan
comprendido dijo que había mucha gente
que estaba afectada por otras realidades
y que no se ofendían y que ellos siempre
jugaban con las imágenes de la historia
y de los east de los grandes personajes
de la historia para hacer promover su
café pero bueno eso sucedió en toronto y
nos recuerda también el caso de un
restaurante en vancouver
el scope bar un restaurante bar en
vancouver que utilizó también la imagen
y el apellido de pablo escobar para
hacer promoción de una cocina latino
canadiense es moderna pero en este caso
se valieron de libertad de expresión
para jugó para jugar con una realidad
que dejó cientos de miles de muertos y
creo ahora si no me equivoco no me
producirá medio millón o no sé cuánto
pero muchísimos muchísimos desplazados
mucha gente que tuvo que dejar su lugar
su vivienda su pueblo su familia no sólo
policial exterior para huir dentro del
territorio colombiano y alejarse de la
violencia eso no es libertad de
expresión no pero más bien le parece a
mi ignorancia entonces y eso fue lo que
estaban diciendo los los colombianos y
los latinos canadienses de toronto ahora
se ha vuelto un símbolo de la moda con
todas las películas en series series
exactamente han salido entre otras cosas
bueno nos tenemos casi que ir yo ya se
nos está acabando el tiempo nos queda un
min
y no dos minutos así que dos minutos y
no hemos abordado temas con alejandra no
tenemos algún otro mensajito así rápido
pero ya los mensajes que tenía aquí para
leer miren no leímos nada entonces no yo
creo que sí
manfred echeverría nos al mandaba
saludos había 10 mensaje ellos por ahí
saludamos a toda la gente entonces que
nos siguió durante el programa les
agradezco a mis colegas leonardo gimeno
leo los graciosos luis labora de nuestro
próximo y también damos la bienvenida
mos las las gracias a la saga méndez que
es candidata por el partido quebec
solidaire en la circunscripción de bug
hasta sube de aquí de montreal muchas
gracias muchísimas gracias gracias a
todos ustedes será hasta la próxima esto
fue canadá en las américas café y el
castor cibernético chau
[Música]
bien
y mucho